>>> IN OUR NATIONAL LEAD, A
TROUBLING BUT SADLY PREDICTABLE
REPORT ON THE CORONAVIRUS
PANDEMIC'S IMPACT ON
SCHOOLCHILDREN.
MATH AND READING SCORES FOR
9-YEAR-OLDS IN THE UNITED STATES
NOT ONLY FELL SHARPLY, BUT HAD
ONE OF THE LARGEST DECLINES ON
RECORD.
CNN'S GABE COHEN TAKES A CLOSER
LOOK AT HOW FAR THIS AGE GROUP
IS FALLING BEHIND, AND HOW THE
PANDEMIC ERASED YEARS WORTH OF
PROGRESS.
>> Reporter: NEW TEST RESULTS
FROM THE NATIONAL ASSESSMENT OF
EDUCATION PROGRESS SHOW MATH AND
READING SCORES FOR 9-YEAR-OLDS
IN THE U.S. FALLING SHARPLY
BETWEEN 2020 AND 2022, THE WORST
DROPOFF FOR READING SINCE 1990.
AND THE FIRST-EVER DECLINE FOR
MATH.
>> THAT IS VERY ALARMING.
IT'S DISTURBING, BUT IT'S NOT
SURPRISING, KEEPING IN MIND A
YEAR AND A HALF AGO, OVER HALF
OF OUR SCHOOLS WERE NOT OPEN FOR
FULL-TIME LEARNING.
>> Reporter: STUDENTS WHO WERE
ALREADY STRUGGLING IN SCHOOL
SHOWED THE MOST DRAMATIC
DROPOFF.
>> SOME COLLEAGUES OF MINE
ESTIMATE THAT IS NINE MONTHS
WORTH OF INSTRUCTION.
>> HOW LONG COULD IT TAKE THESE
STUDENTS TO CATCH UP?
>> IN MY VIEW, A NUMBER OF YEARS
BEFORE STUDENTS CAN MAKE UP THIS
LOST GROUND IN FULL.
>> I HAVE STUDENTS THAT ARE
COMING INTO 4th GRADE THAT ARE
PERFORMING TWO AND THREE GRADE
LEVELS BELOW WHERE THEY SHOULD
BE.
>> Reporter: NICOLE IS A 4th AND
5th GRADE TEACHER IN TEXAS, WHO
ASKS US NOT TO SHOW HER FACE,
FEARING RETALIATION.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT I CAN MAKE
UP TWO YEARS OF GROWTH IN ONE
YEAR.
>> I DON'T THINK IT'S OVER YET.
WE WILL HAVE TO DO BETTER THAN
WHAT WE WERE DOING BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC.
>> Reporter: SCHOOLS NATIONWIDE
HAVE BEEN TRYING TO HIRE MORE
STAFF, INCLUDING TUTORS AND
PSYCHOLOGISTS.
>> I THINK THE FIRST STEP IS
SIMPLY TO MAKE UP SOME OF THE
LOST INSTRUCTIONAL TIME THAT
COULD COME THROUGH EXTENDED
SCHOOL CASE, AFTER SCHOOL
PROGRAMMING AND TUTORING, AND
COME THROUGH SUMMER SCHOOL
PROGRAMS.
>> Reporter: BUT WITH TEACHER
BURNOUT AND A SHRINKING PEPLINE,
MANY SCHOOLS FACE A TEACHER
SHORTAGE, ESPECIALLY IN RURAL
AREAS AND THOSE WITH MORE LOW
INCOME FAMILIES AND STUDENTS OF
COLOR.
AND RIGHT NOW, THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IS PUMPING MORE THAN
$100 BILLION IN RELIEF FUNDS
INTO SCHOOLS AND REQUIRING THEM
TO SPEND AT LEAST 20% OF IT ON
THIS LEARNING LOSS.
BUT KAITLAN, IN THE SHORT TERM,
AT THOSE SCHOOLS THAT CAN'T FIND
ENOUGH TEACHERS RIGHT NOW,
STUDENTS WHO NEED MORE ATTENTION
THAN EVER ARE LIKELY GETTING